そこで自然の変化っていうのは別に気にすることじゃないんです
限度を超えると 限度を超えたっていうことは管理できないっていうこと
もう原発のところで臨界実験が起きたら
もう管理できなくなります
あのチェルノブイルのようになってくると
もうどうにもならん そのままコンクリートで埋めてしまうしかないんです
それでも漏れるは漏れるは漏れるは
もうどうすることもできない
考えてください 巨大なところでしょうに
それ全部コンクリートで埋めなくちゃあかんだから
どれぐらいコンクリート必要ですか
しかし これ機械で持っていけませんよ
近寄れませんだから どうやってって
無理です 空からコンクリートを流し込まなくちゃあかんだから
空にいたっても放射能が行くんだからね
だからといって ヘリにそんなたくさんコンクリート運べませんよ
だから まあまあ 表だけで大丈夫
もう安全でシールしているんだぞというだけで
もうものすごい危険なことは起きることは起きてはいるんです
どこでもそうやって限度を超えちゃうと管理できなくなる
だから物事に手を加えても
限度だけは気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
我々には自然が暴走しているように感じるが
自然は暴走しません 私たちは自然が暴走しているんだと勘違いです
自然は自然です 問題はこちらで管理できなかっただけ
因縁に手を加えることは不可能だけです
だから因縁には手を加えられません
手加えたとしたっても因縁なんです
次は地雷を踏まないこと
科学 経済 政治 家族などの管理においても
人の生き方 精神 心においても
原因を 何でしたか？これは
うん いじって原因をいじって流れを勝手に変えても構わないが
因縁が変えられる範囲にリミットがあることに注意しなくてはならないんです
いじってもいいんです
どうしよう どうしてもいじらなくあかんだからね
好きなようにしなくちゃあかんだからね
しかし リミットがあるんだよと
子供を叱責してもいいんですよ
しかし リミットがあるんです
旦那に怒鳴っても構いませんよ
リミットがあるんです
これを超えると もう管理不可能
人をからかってもいいんですよ
しかし 限度があります
あらゆるものに限度があるんです
世界も己の心も手に負えない状態になるまでいじらないこと
我々はこの物事をいじって
子供をいじって不良にするとかね
まあいろいろありますけど
我々自分の心もいじってますよ
そうすると自分の心であっても自己管理できなくなる
暴走します 俗世間の言葉で言えば暴走します
本当は暴走してないんです
自然に流れているだけ
だから地雷を踏まないことです
人生は 地雷一旦踏んだらまあ諦めるしかないんです
もう足をもう外せませんよ
だからじっと踏んだままでいられません
だからね そう言ったらそのまま死ぬでしょうに
足を上げたらまた死ぬでしょう
というわけで 自然を変えようと思って勝手にするのは言うんだけど
いいんだけど 限度守らなくちゃあかんです
できるだけ はい